breaking news now according to TMZ
legendary actress director and producer
Penny Marshall has died at 75 years old
again TMZ is reporting this that
Marshall died just a matter of hours ago
on Monday 75 years old known perhaps
best for her iconic role playing Laverne
on the hit sitcom Laverne and Shirley
she was nominated for three Golden
Globes for that show won twice for Best
Actress in a TV series Musical or Comedy
but that was from 1976 to 1983 after
that Marshall went on to bigger and
better things including the movie big
she's known for being the first woman
ever to hit 100 million dollars at the
box office with a film she directed that
is the movie big starring Tom Hanks
penny had not been as active in her
acting in recent or directing really in
recent years she done spots guest spots
here there on sitcoms she appeared on
the remake of The Odd Couple starring
Matthew Perry some years ago in one role
but she did have one project per IMDB in
the works interestingly she's down for
having directed a documentary about NBA
iconic player Dennis Rodman according to
IMDB Rodman said he would only trust
director Penny Marshall with the story
the sister of the late iconic director
Garry Marshall who died in 2016 he was
in his 80s again according to TMZ Penny
Marshall reportedly has died at age 75
[Music]
[Applause]